hola sara soy carol en solo quería que
supieras que hemos tenido la primera
mujer de eeuu que solicita un aborto
viene de ohio los preparativos están en
marcha en esta clínica de aborto de
toronto para algo que nunca pensaron que
sucedería tratar a una paciente
estadounidense muchas de las personas
con las que hemos hablado en eeuu
sienten probablemente que la primera
opción sería tratar de ir a otro estado
haremos todo lo posible para acomodar a
las mujeres que vienen de eeuu los
defensores del derecho a decidir dicen
que eeuu acaba de retroceder 50 años
algo que no quieren que suceda en canadá
australia y la mayoría de nosotros nunca
pensamos hace diez años que romper sus
waits sería derogada y ahora tenemos que
reexaminar nuestros pensamientos y cómo
es la atención del aborto en canadá
entonces creo que eso nos dio una
pequeña llamada de atención en canadá
tras la anulación de roe versus wade
canadá invirtió 3,5 millones de dólares
para mejorar el acceso al aborto en el
país en algunos casos las mujeres
todavía tienen que viajar a través de
canadá para obtener atención
especializada
es el derecho elegir es un derecho de la
mujer y sólo suyo nunca retrocederemos
en proteger y promover el acceso al
aborto seguro en canadá y en todo el
mundo y no podemos dar por sentado
ningún derecho incluido este fundamental
la inversión está destinada a
tranquilizar a las mujeres incluso a
pesar de la envalentonada oposición anti
aborto bryant jenkins está entre ellos
protesta todas las mañanas frente a esta
clínica de abortos en montreal
la noticia de eeuu fue bien recibida
estábamos felices yo estaba feliz es un
gran paso en la vida es importante debe
vencer a la muerte el partido
conservador en canadá dice que no quiere
reabrir el debate sobre el aborto pero
una docena de miembros de sus
funcionarios electos están abiertamente
en contra de esta práctica